[Musik]
und ich weiß nicht ist ein gefühl gut
zweimal ist die prüfung schon vorbei ja
ich bin gerade fertig geworden ich
dachte schon wir kommen viel zu spät
ich muss mit ihm reden
nico du musst nicht sagen ich hätte dich
niemals an diese situation bringt dürfen
welche situation
du solltest dich niemals beschmierten
entscheiden müssen das war es nicht
allein
ich weiß und ich wünsche mir auch dass
wir einfach so zusammen sein können
ich würde alles dafür geben aber das
können wir nicht
weißt du ich habe angst dass du es
bereuen würdest wenn du dich jetzt für
mich entscheiden meine familie ist ein
totales chaos
und ich werde nicht der grund dafür sein
dass noch eine andere kaputt geht
zum schluss
wir waren wir zusammen sein
[Musik]